I can show you the world I'll come back
to Ghana with me Josh Anton house and
today in addition we have the stars of
the innocence which is a killer new
Netflix series we need us
[Music]
you've cooked hell peak where she look
[Music]
this whole TV drama is about
shape-shifting yes so we're gonna play a
quick game with you
I have a knack she loads of this I know
you gonna be doing a celebrity name and
a well-known love song and you have to
impersonate the person have to guess who
it is
here we go how good are you impressions
you bet to see ok I can show you the
world shining shimmering splendid tell
me princess now when we did you last let
your heart decide
I can open your eyes take you wonder by
wonder over sideways and under on a
magic carpet ride a whole new world can
I just say that is way better
that's like a whole new world for that
song isn't there you'd ever know with
the song is that's the lab day I know
I've no pressure
that's Aladdin yeah a whole new world I
just I just yeah I rat Aladdin I
supposed to be M cardi B oh yes she's
like the book I could show you the world
dude
I'm trying to help you we're gonna see
how while you can shape-shift into some
celebrity Oh
oh my god these are hilarious I'm
standing there on a balcony in the
summer ere seeing the lights see the
party the ball gowns no you're not
getting along is Taylor Swift yeah
lollipop oh my Cyrus no like the
original like Miley but before that
Britney yeah but that's not really how
she talked I was just trying to like the
nasal okay yeah it's so crazy right now
it's your boy young you ready you ready
you don't wanna bang oh yes okay where
the Eagles cry on a mountain high love
lift us up where we belong this is
someone be famous yes so famous but my
voice isn't low enough to do it real
life welcome freemen yes there we go I'd
kill dead
brilliant possibly shame thank you very
much does that mean that I'm like an
actual actor and I